Jennifer you with us right now Jennifer
yesterday a tough loss but immediately
bounced back and you played a very good
friend of yours Rochelle Wu today is
that a Bittersweet victory for you
yeah I mean I feel like Russell is like
my little sister but you know in these
kind of tournaments we get used to
playing against each other like we
always play against each other Juniors
and I actually always do really bad
against her I always play like my worst
game of my life against her so I'm glad
I didn't lose this game
um but yeah
let's discuss uh today's game because it
was actually quite tense out of the
opening yeah I um did not do the best
prep so I wasn't expecting Asics she
told me she played this yesterday but I
thought she was gonna go E6 first
um but wait wait she told you that she's
going to play this against you yesterday
no after the round I was like I was like
oh I wasn't expecting 86 and she said
she played this yesterday against Alice
and I saw like a position but I thought
it was a different move order
um I was just yeah so I haven't played
this that's why
um and I looked at this years ago for
black so I didn't really remember I just
remember C5
um was like something I was looking at
but
I think this is normal but I
um just trying to create uh come up with
a plan because this part was like really
tricky here and
it might not have done I think C5 ideas
yeah so Knight takes C5
um I looked at this for a while and I
think I really liked the position after
something like 95 or even takes on e4 oh
Knight to E5 yeah I was the deciding
between them like if she was gonna play
this um I just saw that like I was happy
with this continuation
um because you're gonna get to take here
maybe and take on C6 yeah
get the Palm back and I think you know
I'm kind of active even though I'm not
completely developed on the king side
Bishop D3 maybe Castle you definitely
gain some speed and she decided to go
Knight C3 Queen takes C3 and then she
was looking to play E5 which makes a lot
of sense in this type of structures
how would you did you assess the
position at this point
before I was really happy
for um because I think if she kept it
like kind of tense in the center there
play Queen E7
um or queen E7 I think is better
um it's just you know it is really
complicated I don't know maybe what the
I don't know what the objective
evaluation is it's like around okay
not feel like it was plus one
um but it's just the thing is I guess
it's hard for her to come up with a plan
because she if she doesn't push on e4
it's like it's not clear what to do and
I just develop but also I don't know
exactly how I would continue like maybe
just be sure because at least you have a
couple of games I've a few moves and
then they have to come up with a plan
and then that's like the thing that's so
tricky about this is I have this nice
space Advantage but it's like what do I
do with that absolutely and uh
she played E4 and you said that you were
happy after this one
is
I just felt like
after especially after she moved the
night from D7 I just felt like I
it's very easy for me to play here now
which wasn't the case um she kept on E5
like maybe I was objectively better but
here I just you know put my Rook to the
open file and just kind of um develop
maybe I'll move the night I was thinking
moving tonight talking to E2 to G3 but
and it doesn't seem like she has a lot
of counterplay yes
and this is what happened she was trying
to find some counter play of course with
F4
yeah don't think this quite works at
this point it seems like you're just
simply breaking through and actually the
king in the center is pretty safe for
you yeah
Jennifer uh a big game for you A big
bounce back a victory how do you feel
about your chances going in the last
five rounds
the thing is like the last few days have
been
um like the last few games especially
since like the rest day were not that
great
um but I was also like I had kind of
struggling because I was um I had a lot
of academic stuff going on so I like I
think it's pretty obvious from my
openings I was there was not that much
prep
um so I'm honestly I felt like like
against Alice I was like really happy
just didn't lose that game
um because you know I was born in like
three hours of sleep and turning the
paper right before right before the game
started so um now I'm just you know
trying to because I think I got like
some things out of the way
um I can really like put my mind more on
this tournament
um because it's just like weird juggling
everything but you know
I mean it's pretty good situation to be
and I think you might hide for a second
I don't really know I think so yeah yeah
um I think Megan won and Megan won so
she's uh at she's the leader probably
okay in the last five okay yeah I mean
it's like a good spot to be like I was
kind of discouraged yesterday I was like
I don't know what I'm doing and the way
I played was just really bad I couldn't
like I just wasted all my time beginning
to but you know I mean there's still
half the tournament love which is weird
but it's a long tournament still plenty
of rounds to go we'll let you get uh
some rest more than three hours of sleep
hopefully we'll see you tomorrow uh
Jennifer quick question for you because
I saw a position and I was kind of
shocked for a moment that like you had
allowed this possibility I've got this
position after move 14 E3 you just
played the move E3 and I just flashed uh
to this moment and I saw that Rochelle
had an opportunity for Knight D7 take C5
what was your intention to play if she
is captured um Planet Fitness yeah oh
okay so I was kind of juggling between
Knight takes E4 and 95 but
um I thought regardless I could just get
the pawn back first like and then I felt
comfortable especially 95 actually liked
a lot
okay I I mean so like you you didn't
blunder the pawn or anything like that
and only noticed it later because at the
moment I mean it was like wow if you can
grab that C5 Pawn for free that's a
different my all together all together
yeah so that's why I thought like 94 was
a really good move by her because
um she has to take advantage of like
this temporary weakness here exactly
Jennifer uh you're on a roller coaster
ride uh
keep right riding the roller coaster go
girl
congratulations yes great result today
well done